as the saying goes a man's home is his
castle there is no one factor more
representative of the economic
well-being of the American citizens than
the home in which he lived it's not just
the American Dream across the rich world
people have been told they should be
buying their own home now's the time to
buy a home get on the housing ladder
starting from under $60,000 helped by
just helping people get their foot on
the housing ladder owning a home is a
part of that dream but why is there this
pressure to get on the property ladder
people don't really question the idea
that homeownership is a good thing it's
something that they've always been told
and as soon as it must be true
the obsession with home ownership has
had unintended consequences which have
not only distorted the housing market
who brought the financial system to its
knees the realization of the American
Dream the envy of the entire world
[Music]
this is Tim he rents in London
this is Deanna she rents in Zurich Tim
is 30 and works in sales and he's
desperate to get on the property ladder
it's incredibly frustrating not to be
able to own something of your own but
Deanna is in no such rush I've been
renting for the whole 20 years since I
came to Switzerland
Deanna rents this apartment with her
twin sons and her partner what a visit
nd not if loogies super she works as a
lecturer at University we've been here
for three years and it's really home for
us Switzerland is one of the world's
most competitive economies and the
people who live here enjoy a very high
quality of life you'd think that would
mean that most people would own their
own home far from it at 38% Switzerland
has the lowest home ownership rate in
the OECD a group of mostly rich
countries in Britain it's much higher
two-thirds of houses are owned by the
people who live in them according to the
economists house price index the Swiss
housing market is considerably more
stable than Britain's a house in
Switzerland is worth to 70% more today
than it was in 1970 in Britain prices
have increased by three hundred and
forty six percent in the same period
there's evidence to show that ownership
rates and market volatility are
connected to understand why we need to
go back 100 years
[Applause]
at the beginning of the 20th century the
majority of people in Britain America
and other developed countries were
renters in Britain for example just one
in four families owned their own home
but after the Second World War many
governments across the rich world made a
monumental shift in policy they decided
to create nations of homeowners the idea
was that if you're a homeowner when you
retire you can sell your home and you
can maybe live off the proceeds of that
or if you lose your job than you've at
least you've got some assets which you
can sell policies such as low interest
loans tax breaks or mortgages and relief
on capital gains tax were put in place
to promote home ownership all of which
add up to quite a big kind of
ineffective subsidy from the government
for home ownership from the 1950s home
ownership shot up as did the amount of
money banks gave in mortgages by 2008
mortgage lending was worth 63% of rich
countries GDP but in the long run this
new world of homeowners created more
problems than it solves
financial catastrophe no and it seems
can stop the bleeding
the big massive global financial crisis
of ten years ago was a housing crisis as
homeowners defaulted on their mortgages
at record rates it was clear trouble was
before a lot of people in America they
thought they were making a sensible
financial decision by becoming
homeowners and that turned out to be
completely wrong the crash was a
disastrous consequence of the
homeownership boom
but the damage caused by encouraging
people to buy their own houses runs far
deeper than financial crises the
fundamental problem is to do with lack
of supplies the whole rich world today
builds like half the houses per person
than it did in the 1960s the declining
construction has been kind of
concentrated in the parts of the country
where you'd most like it to increase so
in those like rich dynamic productive
cool cities since the first day I
arrived in London I've been looking at
house prices I think there's an innate
human drive to own something and to call
it your own but when people do buy their
own home
they're more likely to resist further
development in their area
Christian hilber has extensively
researched the impact of this mentality
in a country where the homeownership
rate is very high homeowners are
so-called named things not in my back
yard residents they try to protect their
asset values by limiting a new supply
they vote for politicians that enforce
restrictive planning that leads to
unresponsive supply so if the economy is
booming and supply cannot respond it
rises prices Lots so in countries like
the UK or the US where homeownership
rates are fairly high these countries
tend to have policies that favor
homeownership and tend to have planning
systems that need to inflexible supply
there's always this question of we'd
like housing for young people but we're
not going to let it ruin our
neighborhood and I think this mentality
this snobbery is absolutely out of
control that has to change because
people in the millennial generation
aren't able to get the basics they need
in life such as a house the failure to
build in particular and cities has also
held back productivity and harmed
economies when you've got expensive
housing it means it's hard for people to
move to those cities and when it's hard
for people to move to their cities it
means that they struggle to get the jobs
that they want and what that basically
does is constrains the growth of the
overall economy
homebuyers are less likely to become
entrepreneurs and less willing to move
to find work research has shown that
historically an increase in home
ownership in America has been followed
by a sharp rise in unemployment as
people are reluctant to relocate to find
a new job
the financial crisis put an end to the
growing rate of homeowners weak earnings
growth and tighter restrictions and
mortgages have made it much harder for
people like Tim to get on the housing
ladder politicians are worried about
declining home ownership
we're helping every American find their
path to the American dream but in fact
having more renters may not be such a
bad thing there's this perception
because much of the world that home
owning is better than renting it creates
a more stable better society in reality
there's only very weak evidence that
home ownership kind of creates better
citizens supporters of homeownership
often cite Singapore as an example of a
highly stable country where ownership is
high they're 91 percent of the
population owned their own home and it
comes ninth in the world on the UN's
Human Development Index but if we look
at Romania there the homeownership rate
is even higher but it comes much lower
in the world in terms of development
which brings us back to Switzerland here
few owned their own homes yet it's one
of the most developed countries in the
world
[Music]
Switzerland also has a system which
benefits renters like Deana renters
rights are protected leases can last as
long as 20 years and prices are stable
you know those years we had never get an
increased price even once you could make
a request to our landlord to reduce the
price because the reference interest
rates were also reduced and according to
the law we just wrote a letter very
short and three months later we got a
new lower price I think
Switzerland is special with regards to
his rental law I wouldn't feel so secure
in another country renters feel very
insecure in this country we don't feel
we're getting a good deal
we don't feel we're getting good value
for money my main incentive for wanting
to buy property is to stop throwing away
money every month on rent this is a
common argument against renting but is
it true in 2018
renters across most of the rich world
did spend more on rent than homeowners
spent on mortgage repayments but to see
the full picture we need to look at all
the costs over a longer period let's
imagine someone choosing between renting
or buying in Britain if they decided to
rent they would give one payment to a
landlord every month but if they decided
to buy their costs would include
mortgage repayments plus interest which
can fluctuate and then a whole host of
additional costs such as transactional
costs buildings insurance and
maintenance once you add up all of those
costs there are times when renting is
better deal and there's times when
homeownership is a better deal when that
depends quite a lot the interest rate in
the economy but both the theory and the
evidence suggests that renting and
buying a property end up costing about
the same amount kind of over that over
the long-run the question of which is
better ultimately comes down to a
personal preference but the idea that
one is inherently an object to be better
than the other
is not true investing in bricks and
mortar isn't always a safe bet while
many have gained from increasing house
values since the 70s
those who piled into the American
housing market to the peak of the bubble
lost out
despite this rich world governments
continue to invest in promoting
homeownership in America and in many
other countries there is what's known as
mortgage interest deduction this is
where homeowners can offset the interest
on their mortgage against income tax the
u.s. spends about 100 billion u.s.
dollars a year on the mortgage interest
deduction in the form of foregone tax
revenue and the net effect of the policy
on home ownership is essentially zero
Christian also looked at a British
policy called help to buy which is a
form of equity loan from the government
the healthy by policy is a very
ineffective policy the bank that helped
you buy in the Greater London Authority
increased house prices by more than the
implied subsidy and it didn't lead to
any new housing construction the case
for the government spending all this
money on promoting homeownership is
quite weak and they could be putting
that money towards education or
transport or health care rather than
creating a stable society home ownership
has been the West's biggest economic
policy mistake attempts are being made
to redress the balance America has
capped its tax break or mortgage
interest deduction and Britain has
banned letting agents from charging
renters fees but that's not enough it's
time to build an entirely new housing
market one that actually works
a manner I directed this film if you'd
like to learn more about the mistakes
governments are made when it comes to
housing you can click on the link
opposite that will take you to a special
report by Kalyan Williams and also some
of the data and research we used while
making this film as always don't forget
to Like and subscribe to our channel
thanks for watching
[Music]
you